jusqu'à présent l'inflation reste quand
même très déterminés par ce qui se passe
du côté des prix de l'énergie pétrole
gaz électricité s'est pas seulement le
pétrole on le sait bien mais également
et de plus en plus par les prix des
produits alimentaires sur ce graphique
vous avez quand vous faites la somme des
bâtons bleu et orange sur le dernier
mois connu pour une inflation à 5 8%
vous expliquez 60% de l'inflation par
les seule composante énergie et
alimentation alors qu'elles représentent
25% à peu près du panier de consommation
des ménages donc on avait une toujours
une surdétermination par des chocs qui
sont de nature plutôt exogènes des
champions l'alimentaire sont également
en bonne partie exogènes parce que ça ah
tiens notamment à des prix des prix de
moyens de production agricole qui sont
très fortement à la hausse mais
l'énergie est un choc qui est bien
plutôt d'un mouvement de prix d'une
question d'approvisionnement mais pour
autant il ya quand même des signaux qui
disent bien qu'on a changé de régime
d'inflation une manière de la précise
c'est de regarder alors ce graphique est
un peu un peu complexe c'est à dire que
on a regardé les les contributions en
point à l'inflation pour chacune des
quatre grandes composantes énergie
alimentation produits manufacturés et
services est en fait ce que la manière
de lire ce graphique consiste à regarder
l'écart qu'il ya entre la contribution
aujourd'hui et la contribution moyenne
sur longue période qu'exerce chacune de
ses quatre composantes en fait on voit
que pour ses quatre composantes
l'inflation fall la contribution que
l'on a actuellement est bien au delà de
la contribution moyenne qu'exerce chacun
de ces postes à l'inflation d'ensemble
en cas on est passé d'un d'un choc
d'inflation très concentré sur l'énergie
un choc qui désormais s'est répandu au
delà concerne les prix les produits
manufacturés parce qu'il ya eu aussi la
hausse des prix des matières premières
hors énergie les métaux notamment ça
s'est répandue sur les services parce
qu'on a un début d'accélération de
l'ensemble du système de prix qui est
embarqué dans les prix des services et
donc vous avez une forme de diffusion de
l'inflation et cette diffusion ne semble
pas devoir s'arrêter puisque les les
anticipations formulées par les chefs
d'entreprise sont toujours des
anticipations de hausses de prix et ce
de manière quand même très marquée en r4
écart type c'est une proportion qui est
tout à fait exceptionnel 4 écart type
pour les opinions des commerçants de
détails sur l'évolution qu'ils
anticipent des prix mais ça vaut aussi
pour la construction pour l'industrie
pour le secteur des services alors
qu'est ce que représente qu'elle est là
qu est ce qu'aujourd'hui veut dire cette
inflation qu'est ce que cela fait comme
amputation du pouvoir d'achat du revenu
des ménages on a essayé de faire un
calcul tout simple on a pas du tout de
prévisions sur 7 à ce stade on a
simplement regarder l'inflation que l'on
a constatée sur les six premier mois et
en a fait l'hypothèse qu'à partir de
maintenant
l'un disait prix reste inchangé et ça on
l'a fait pour aller à les pays européens
que vous avez sur sur ce tabou et donc
si il ne devait plus y avoir de nouvelle
accélération des prix à partir du mois
de juin alors sur l'ensemble de l'année
relativement à l'année 2000 21 le choc
d'inflation que l'on connaît
représenterait un choc etc santé un choc
toutes choses égales par ailleurs 2 66
milliards d'euros en france a fait donc
66 milliards c'est ça tombe bien ça
c'est facile ça fait à peu près 1000
euros par habitant en france ça fait 4 %
du revenu des ménages quelques
proportion du revenu des ménages
l'énergie à elle seule sait la moitié de
ce choc d'inflation ces 500 euros par an
par habitant par habitant voyez pas par
ménages par habitant pour la seule
énergie notez aussi que c'est en france
que ce choc est le plus amorti pour
l'ensemble de la zone euro se choque
c'est 1288 euros par par habitant pour
l'allemagne en est à 1450 donc on a
plutôt à plus amorti par l'intermédiaire
des prix par le jeu sur les prix en
france que cela a été le cas dans les
autres pays européens et d'ailleurs
quand on regarde sur un peu plus longue
période pas seulement sur le choc de
2002 2022 quand on regarde sur plus
longue période
avec des prévisions d'une inflation qui
seraient en moyenne annuelle un peu
supérieure à 5% et une progression de
pouvoir d'achat du revenu des ménages de
revenus des ménages aux environs de 2 4%
on va avoir une baisse sur l'ensemble de
l'année les pouvoirs d'achat du revenu
des ménages mais au total par rapport à
2010 9 par rapport à la vente qu'ovide
la france sera la seule des quatre
grandes économies de la zone euro à
avoir un niveau du du revenu réel des
ménages supérieur à celui que l'on
connaissait donc avant le coville alors
qu on sera à peu près 5 points en
dessous pour l'allemagne de point en
dessous pour pour l'italie d'en dessous
du niveau de 2010 9 et 5 points en
dessous pour ce qui concerne ce qui
concerne l'espagne et pour autant mais
quand là on parle jusqu'à présent j'ai
parlé d'un pouvoir d'achat de l'ensemble
des ménages quand ensuite on va des
composés quand on va regarder le
comportement en fin de ce que ressentent
chaque ménage pris individuellement bien
on se rend compte qu'il y à une perte du
revenu disponible brut réel par ménage
puisqu'il ya une progression du nombre
de ménages qui est grosso modo le double
de la progression du nombre d'habitantes
et en 2022 il est probable que l'on se
retrouve avec un niveau de revenu
disponible brut réel par ménage
intérieur à ce que l'on avait en 2009
mais également inférieurs à ceux que
l'on connaissait en 2010 c'est la courbe
entrée vers que vous avez sur ce
graphique donc on a bien un pouvoir
d'achat de l'ensemble des ménages qui
est au dessus du niveau de 2010 neuf et
dix points au dessus du niveau de 2010
mais en revanche il est inférieur quand
on le regarde quand on prend en compte
la structure démographique l'évolution
de la structure démographique
un autre point mais là qui est plus de
la sueur de la réflexion en termes de
dynamique économique qu'est ce que
représente aujourd'hui le choc
d'inflation par rapport à l'assuré panne
qui a été constitué par les ménages
pendant la période qu'ovide donc il ya
eu abondance de formation des pagnes par
les ménages qui étaient empêchés de
consommer mais qui ont vu plutôt leurs
revenus préserver et ses revenus ont été
épargnés et il y avait notamment une
hypothèse de voir réinjectée dans le
circuit à un moment ou un autre cette
épargne pour pouvoir stimuler la
consommation en fait c'était pas une
partie se trouve écornée se trouve élimé
le passage de l'inflation et donc on a
estimé que ces 43 % de l'assuré panne
qui a été constituée en 2020 2021 là
encore toutes choses égales par ailleurs
qu'ils se trouvent et limay par le
passage de la consommation donc si vous
voulez l'assuré pagnes et bien
réintroduite par le circuit mais pas
sous forme de dépenses additionnelles
mais pour pouvoir au moins maintenir le
niveau de l'eau niveau de dépenses des
ménages une bonne partie se retrouver
corner et un autre point qui nous
semblait assez important à regarder
c'est ce qui se passe du côté des dépôts
réels des ménages à ceux ci sont en
train de sont en train de s'éroder alors
face à cela quels sont les comportements
qu'elles sont à quai ce qu'on peut
imaginer en termes de de progression
d'une progression du revenu et notamment
dé progression des revenus salariaux en
particules en provenance des entreprises
sage m'arrête je laisserais agnès se
complétaient bien évidemment sur la
partie sa partie était je vais me
concentrer plus sur la partie
répercussions désormais en termes de
revenus et notamment en termes de
salaires ce que l'on voit déjà dans un
premier temps sur le comportement des
entreprises alors celle ci subissent un
choc de prix en amont choc de prix
matières premières le choc de prix en
fin de l'ensemble de leurs coûts et
quand on regarde la dynamique des prix
relatifs eh bien on a plutôt une
déformation fagnes une recul du prix
relatif des entreprises relativement à
leurs coûts d'approvisionnement et si on
le regarde avec le rapport des prix à la
production sur le prix des consommations
intermédiaires donné par les comptes
nationaux on voit par exemple que dans
le secteur de la construction le prix et
la corruption ne suis pas du tout c'est
là où je suis le moins même l'évolution
des prix à la consommation intermédiaire
donc il ya un
amortisseur si vous voulez qu'ils aient
pris dans les dents les marges des
entreprises de notamment par cet
intermédiaire et on le voit encore mieux
sur le sur le graphique suivant ou
compte tenu des évolutions des de la
structure de coûts à des entreprises on
se retrouve déjà avec un niveau de
résultat d'exploitation des entreprises
rapporté à la valeur de leur production
et non pas à la valeur ajoutée mais a
rapporté à la valeur de la production on
se retrouve à des niveaux qui sont assez
proches des points bas que l'on
connaissait en 2012 2013 oui il ya eu là
la forte boss qui est intervenu en 2021
avec tous les dispositifs dead qui ont
été déployés les fonds de stabilisation
notamment qui est qui on est et qui a
été déployé mais ces dispositifs n'ont
plus cours
c'est la fin logique enfin sorti de la
période ces dispositifs n'ont plus cours
s'ajoutent là dessus un choc de prix de
matières premières un choc de prix en un
mot qui n'est pas intégralement
répercutée donc on a alors plutôt en
recul du résultat d'exploitation et
sociétés non financières s'ajoute à cela
la question de l'évolution des salaires
alors ce que l'on peut voir pour
l'instant sur les salaires c'est que le
salaire mensuel de base bien il
progresse faiblement mail du côté quand
on regarde le salaire moyen par tête les
entreprises ont qu à un salaire qui va
incorporer également les primes on est
sur une progression sur un an qui est de
6,7 pour cent 3 % en termes réels mais
bon je le regardais sur un nom sympa
tellement de sens je préfère le regarder
le lycée un petit peu vous voyez les
mouvements de combat qu'a eue le salaire
moyen par tête avec la paire est qu vide
je préfère le regarder par rapport à
2019 le salaire moyen par tête est en
progression de 5,1 pour cent par rapport
à 2010 9 quand on prend le niveau du
premier trimestre 2001 22 par rapport à
la moyenne 2019 ce qui fait du 0 2% en
termes réels donc on a une stagnation du
salaire moyen par tête réel dans l'est
dans les sociétés non financières est ce
qu'il ya de la place pour distribuer du
salaire ce qui fait quand même la
progression des salaires à long terme ce
sont les gains de productivité et quand
on regarde la canton mais au regard la
productivité horaire
elle dont les branches marchande et le
salaire horaire réel on se rend compte
qu'il y a plutôt bien moins de
progression de productivité que de
progression de salaire donc les salaires
sont allés un peu au delà de ce que le
fondamental économique permettrait les
gains de productivité sont très en deçà
de la progression du salaire réel quel
que soit le déflateur que l'on utilise
donc les marges d'augmentations
salariales sont dépendantes des
évolutions de productivité est pour
l'instant ces évolutions ne sont ne sont
pas très vite or pour retomber qu'est ce
qui est en train de se faire sur sur les
salaires notamment j'insisterai sur sur
la partie de la discussion
conventionnelle des désaccords des
accords de branche
il ya une note qui était très
intéressante qui était faite par la
banque de france au moins deux mois de
mai pour essayer de positionner où on en
était en cas d'accord de branche
ou à la fin de l'année 2021 les
négociations sur les minima de branche
c'était une augmentation comprise entre
2,5 et 3,5 pour cent c'était un pur sang
2021 avec des clauses de revoyure qui
ont été beaucoup plus fréquentes qui ont
été incorporés dans les accords de
branche qui était beaucoup plus
fréquente que ce que l'on observe
habituellement et donc les clauses de
revoyure sont en train de s'exercer dans
un certain nombre de range d'autant que
les évolutions du smic sans compter la
prochaine qui va intervenir au 1er août
les évolutions à du smic font un
secret on fait passer les minima de
branche en dessous du smic dans de
nombreuses branches alors il y ait
quelques écueils quelques relations
économiques qui sont rappelées là dessus
ce qui fait l'évolution fallait
ce sont ces l'inflation qui est vraiment
déterminante des minima de branche qu'on
a plutôt devant nous une accélération
des minima de branche c'est 0 6 point
quand vous avez une inflation un point
vous avez 0,6 point en moyenne
d'augmentation des minima de branche
donc on peut on peut s'attendre à ce que
comme on aura une évolution des prix qui
se rabat un peu supérieure à 5% fin 2022
il est probable que l'accélération des
minima va se poursuivre et donc il ya
une progression régulière des régulière
des salaires sans pour autant que
forcément complètement annulé
l'inflation mais là encore il ya un jeu
entre les primes et les salaires gl
terminera juste sur un point qui était
un peu en filigrane de ce que j'évoquais
sur la comparaison du du revenu
disponible brut des ménages contre la
france et les autres pays de la zone
euro on est sur une dispersion
d'inflation qui est tout à fait
exceptionnel à l'intérieur de la zone
euro et qui va poser un moment ou un
autre des problèmes on sait qu une bonne
partie de cette de cette moindre
inflation en france tient à
l'intervention directe qui a été fait
sur le niveau des prix et ce qui peut
peut-être induire si on imagine qu'à peu
près les mêmes les mêmes élasticité des
salaires par rapport aux prix dans la
plupart des pays européens cela va
induire à à une redistribution des
cartes en matière de compétitivité
salariale au sein de la zone euro sauf
que cette compétitivité salariale elle
aura été notamment permise en france par
une intervention budgétaire extrêmement
importante qui va nous mettre dans une
situation de déséquilibre budgétaire
plus importante plus dégradée que la
beaucoup de pays européens et donc ça on
risque d'avoir quand même à de nouvelles
contraintes qui va s'exercer en fin de
1re sentiment peut-être en leader d'une
heure qui viendra de 7,2 ce décalage
d'inflation qui est intervenue mais là
c'est c'est juste un risque que je
voulais je voulais évoquer très bien
merci monsieur ferrand et vous vous avez
montré que évidemment le losc ont
préparé un beau feuilleton pouvait
gagner cinq minutes de plus ça nous a
abandonnés avec beaucoup de plaisir mais
je ne souhaite pas encourager les
suivants
affolons g dans cette durée vous nous
avez également évidemment
fait un exposé et c'est très logique
compte tenu de l'institut que vous
représentez aucun peu sous l'angle entre
l'entreprise et des salariés des
entreprises bien entendu c'était ce
qu'on attendait d'ailleurs de vous dans
cette table ronde madame bénassy quéré
vous laisser encore votre place ou donc
merci beaucoup monsieur le président en
fait comme ça ça va me permettre de ne
pas répéter ce qu'a dit avec beaucoup de
pédagogie denis un instant peut-être
pour compléter sur certains points et
puis développer d'autres sur le
l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat les
salaires alors les salaires bon je pense
que il a montré des salaires par tête
jeu il faut peut-être les corrigés par
l'activité partielle pendant là parce
que enfin là on a ce grand v en 2020 en
fait l'activité partielle ce qui fait
que c'est un peu en trompe l'oeil ce v
aurait été les salariés ont bien reçu
des rémunérations en 2020 donc c'est un
peu compliqué de calculer taux de
croissance à cause de ça
alors
il a enfin je suis vraiment complètement
d'accord il faut qu'on fasse très
attention sur le fait qu' on a vraiment
un décrochage la productivité par
rapport à la fin 2010 9 par rapport à la
tendance pré crise après preco vite
puisqu'en fait on enchaîne les crises
donc mon preco vide on ne serait à peu
près -5% donc c'est tout à fait
important
et donc faut mesurer l'évolution des
salaires par rapport à ça c'est à dire
si on maintient les salaires réels sur
la croissance sur la tendance pré crise
on a un décrochage de produits de la
compétitivité alors soit qui ça soit qui
se prend dans les marges des entreprises
près dans les marges ce qui va avoir
lieu nous on n'est pas encore alarmistes
sur les marges parce que 2021 c'était un
point haut sur les marges donc on
s'attend à une diminution des marges en
effet mais pour revenir à un niveau
proche de 2018 qui est en général point
de comparaison puisque 2009 est un il ya
le double compte cce
donc voilà je voulais remettre un peu
les choses en perspective et et par
rapport au débat actuel sur sur les
salaires aussi puisque
enfin
l'état intervient sur les salaires quand
il a une faille de marché et il ya
classiquement une faille de marché pour
les non qualifiés puisque dans les
prénoms qualifié il ya un marché local
du travail avec en général quelques
employeurs dominants et des des
travailleurs qui eux sont peu coordonnée
et donc c'est une négociation
asymétrique et l'état intervient pas le
salaire minimum pour empêcher le salaire
de tomber trop bas pour les salaires
au-dessus du salaire minimum la
concurrence entre les entreprises
surtout en ce moment où il ya des
contraintes de recrutement et vertueuse
en réalité dire que certaines
entreprises vont pouvoir offrir des
salaires plus élevés attirer à elle les
meilleurs travailleurs et c'est bon pour
la dynamique de la productivité dont je
parlais tout à l'heure qu'elle était en
panne donc je pense que vous faire très
attention à ça que rien n'empêche les
entreprises d'augmenter les salaires
c'est elles peuvent pas descendre en
dessous du smig mais elles peuvent
remonter au dessus on souffre en france
d'avoir une échelle de salaire qui est
très comprimé autour du smic qui crée un
peu de désespérance pour les personnes
qui sont juste au dessus qui qui qui
bouge pas beaucoup qui se sont rattrapés
par le smic donc je pense qu'il faut
faire très attention hein quand on
commence à discuter de plus
d'intervention publique sur les salaires
est également faire très attention que
nous sommes un pays qui a un déficit
commercial ce déficit commercial a
augmenté avec le co vide il n'a pas été
rattrapé depuis
certes il ya des revenus vous avez
peut-être vu les légines la banque de
france il ya des revenus qui rattrape
sur le compte courant c'est assez
classique en france donc c'est plus que
ce qu'on attendait mais il reste qu'on a
un déficit commercial et donc c'est
cette période avec des grosses
divergences d'inflation entre les pays
européens c'est peut être aussi une
occasion pour la france de réaliser son
ajustement paix relatif qu'elle
n'arrivait pas à faire avant la crise
quand il n'y avait pas de quand il n'y
avait pas deux
d'inflation je vais rappeler aussi la
crise de 2009 ou en 2009 pour par
rapport à mentionner sur la productivité
en 2009 la productivité donc avec la
crise financière la productivité a
baissé les salaires ont continué sur
leur lancée et cet écart on n'a pas
rattrapé et essayez donc le gouvernement
a dû le disons le rattraper avec le cic
eux et dont compte tenu de la situation
des finances publiques aujourd'hui il
faut faire quand même très attention il
y aura pas nouveau c'est ce pour
rattraper ce décrochage donc voilà c'est
celle à la première chose que je voulais
dire sur les salaires
sur le soutien public sur le soutien
public alors on a fait des petits
calculs
donc denis l'a bien montré il ya une
partie qui est via moins d'inflation et
puis fallait donc le soutien du pouvoir
d'achat des ménages vient en partie par
balles et les différents dispositifs
blocage des hausses de gaz d'électricité
le carburant etc enfin vous connaissez
tout ça
et l'autre partie c'est via le soutien
au revenu l'échec est donc d'après nos
calculs en 2022 ce serait à peu près
moitié moitié et le total serait presque
2 3% en france donc c'est un soutien
massif pour donner une perspective les
autres grands pays européens c'est de
l'ordre de 1 à 2% le soutien du pouvoir
d'achat via ses différents dispositifs
donc on ne fait pas de miracle
il ya effectivement une situation d'une
foire d'achat qui est meilleure en
france que dans d'autres pays européens
mais c'est c'est grâce à un soutien
public dont sa madeleine au sujet des
soutiens publics est ce que
est ce que
ios qu'on va par rapport au soutien
public et aussi
peut-être donner un peu une analyse par
rapport
aux discussions sur la situation des
finances publiques et le fait que quand
les prix augmentent c'est bien il y aura
des recettes budgétaires et qu'on
pourrait dépenser donc effectivement
quand on regarde un peu les choses au
premier run on se dit avec de
l'inflation il ya plus de recettes de
tva et donc l'état a plus d'argent par
ailleurs la dette est fixé en euro
10 % qui est indexé mais 90% qui n'est
pas indexé et donc rapporter un pub qui
augmente en valeur normalement ça
devrait alléger les finances publiques
alors arrêtez c'est pas faux ça mais
c'est quand même une toute petite partie
de l'histoire et sans le faire trop long
donc à court terme l'ofcl a bien montré
à court terme comme l'indexation des
dépenses est moins rapide que
l'indexation des recettes on a
effectivement un effet positif à
quantité donnée et c'est là que manque
l'essentiel de l'histoire c'est qu'on a
un choc de termes de l'échangé quand on
fait on subit une hausse de notre
énergie importées l'inflation elle ne
vient pas d'un boom de la demande comme
c'est le cas aux états unis au moins en
partie chez nous ça vient de l'inflation
importée dont on sait bien qu'on paye
plus cher pour ont fait des chèques non
seulement en russie mais surtout aux
pays du golfe et cet argent c'est de
l'argent qui va manquer pour les caisses
de l'état donc on peut pas avoir un pays
qui s'appauvrit parce que c'est ça un
chef de termes de l'échangé le pids
appauvri et des finances publiques sont
florissantes c'est pas possible et il a
raison c'est que en volume les assiettes
fiscales diminuent relativement à avant
le choc énergétique donc la consommation
les revenus il ya des révisions des
révisions de la croissance à la baisse
et ça se retrouve dans les finances
publiques donc en ces masques et en 2022
par des recettes exceptionnelles dont
une partie viennent du rebond d'activité
en 21 si on pense au set 10 aces c'est
donc en 2021 il ya eu un rebond des
profits et donc il ya un rebond de lille
est en 2022 mais ça ça va disparaître il
ya aussi une baisse du taux d'épargné
par rapport au niveau exceptionnel de
2020 et 21 donc il a diminué un plan
maintient et de nouveaux 22 mai c'est ça
peut pas continuer éternellement d'en
faire un petit peu attention on a des
effets qui masque
les faits sur les dépenses publiques et
enfin il ya également le fait que quand
on a un chef de termes de l'échangé en
fait les prix à la consommation denis a
bien montré vont plus vite que les prix
la production or les recettes fiscales
sont plus ou moins indexés sur le prix à
la production puisque c'est la valeur
ajoutée qui a ensuite partagé entre le
travail de capital est par contre les
dépenses publiques sont largement
indexée sur les prix la consommation
donc là on a aussi normalement en temps
normal les deux defla les deux prix vont
à peu près pareil mais là c'est pas du
tout le cas en ce moment est donc là
aussi on a une perte enfin sur sur la
dette à court terme donc une partie de
la dette est indexé sur l'inflation
malheureusement c'est une partie de ses
30% de l'inflation française mais 70%
l'inflation en zone euro
donc comme elle va plus vite on a un
effet inflationniste
enfin
un surcoût sur la dette à court terme à
plus long terme c'est naturellement la
hausse des taux qui l'emportent et là
encore sur le r - je vais faire
attention parce que si le 1er au monde
est logé augmentent très bien le taux
d'intérêt - le taux de croissance si les
deux augmente ça va mais le problème
avec un chef de termes de l échange
c'est que on risque d'avoir un air qui
augmente et un jeu qui diminue donc là
encore on a eu un effet boule de neige
qui augmenterait alors pour terminer
vous aviez une question sur les
inégalités par rapport à les inégalités
par rapport à l'inflation un succès qui
n'a pas trop couvert denis juste pour
aller vite jeu juste citer les les
chiffres de l'insee 1 c'était très
intéressant donc ils ont calculé
le choc d'inflation pour différents
types de ménages et donc on voit que les
habitants en zone rurale c'est pas une
surprise un sont plus exposés aux chocs
d'inflation de l'ordre de 1 point de
plus donc une clos lorsque en
en avril 2022 c'était la date de l'étude
le glissement annuel de 4 9 pour la
france entière et bien 75,9 en zone
rurale et par contre les jeunes c'est
presque un point de moins donc c'est
intéressant mais il faut faire attention
ne pas lire ça sans regarder à côté les
soutiens aux revenus et les mécanismes
d'indexation et la jouer a quand même
rappelé que le smic a augmenté de quasi
8% aura au mans aura augmenté en août de
quasi eu pour cent sur un an est donc en
fait les revenus
inférieurs sont relativement bien
protégés si on pense aussi aux minima
sociaux
en zone rurale on peut imaginer aussi
qu'il ya des retraités en assez grand
nombre donc faut faire attention à ça
par rapport au soutien en revenus là
donc un petit calcul montrent que pour
le fruit des cils ça représente donc les
mesures de soutien au pouvoir d'achat un
pour les ménages par dixièmes de revenus
on sait à peu près 6 % du revenu pour le
premier décile 1% pendant dernier décide
donc tout le monde gagne c'est l'état
qui perd mais c'est en pourcentage du
revenu un événement en euros courants
c'est pas pareil puisque le revenu du
premier décile par définition est plus
bas et qu'est ce que on peut attendre
par rapport aux années 70 c'était je
termine juste là
donc on ne sait pas très bien les
anticipations d'inflation pour l'instant
sont ancrées la boucle prix salaires et
pas totalement enclenché mais très
franchement c'est un peu mystérieux ce
qu'on sait par contre c'est que on est
mieux armé dans les années soixante dix
il ya moins d'indexation il ya moins de
dépendance aux jeunes et aux énergies
fossiles et banques centrales sont
indépendantes
il ya de mad men et en les salaires
réels sont moins rigides mais il ya des
éléments qui peuvent quand même qu'ils
sont différentes pas forcément en bien
par rapport aux années 70 il ya beaucoup
d' endettement notamment d'endettement
privé mais aussi publiques des tensions
sur marché du travail qui peuvent
alimenter la boucle prix-salaires une
sur épargne accumulée on sait pas ce qui
va se passer mais elle peut être
éventuellement dépenser et donc ça ça
soutient ça soutient l'inflation voilà
je m'arrêtais la merci beaucoup pour
être à la merci surtout que je vous
rappelle que après nos questions vous
aurez un deuxième petit tour un peu plus
court mais qui vous permettra de prêter
les derniers points éventuellement que
vous aurez donc j'essaie de maintenant
la parole à monsieur mathieu plane
l'adjoint de leif 6e et je veux lui a
rajouté peut-être si jamais il y avait
pas pensé et puisque le sujet n'a pas
encore été abordée
finalement la politique monétaire d'un
par rapport à la lutte contre
l'inflation aujourd'hui ce que c'est la
bonne réponse je le pose de manière un
peu à un peu raide comme ça mais est-ce
que ça répond au sujet non mais je
pouvais intégrer dans votre région et
sinon on propose m'entendais bien oui
bonjour bonjour à tous bonjour à tous je
vais essayer d'être bref est évoquée
effectivement ce sujet de la la réponse
en fait des politiques économiques à
cette inflation qui me semble un sujet
quand même assez crucial
avec le fameux dilemme un des banques
centrales entre agir pour éventuellement
donner un signal en tout cas comme quoi
le
cette inflation pouvait avoir des effets
de second tour et donc remonter les taux
clairement mais avec les effets bien sûr
que ça pourrait avoir en termes de
conséquences sur le coût de
refinancement avec ce qu'a dit agnès à
l'augmentation des dettes notamment et
bien sûr le risque de casser la
croissance alors même que cette
inflation est quand même pour beaucoup
pour le moment d'origine importés et ça
c'est quand même un point important et
notamment pour la france où la zone euro
quand on regarde l'inflation actuelle
globalement on a peu plus de ses propres
et 60% qui liées à l'énergie et
l'alimentaire donc ça veut dire que
l'inflation qui est plutôt d'origine
domestique reste relativement maîtrisée
ça veut dire que ça veut pas dire qui a
pas d'inflation mais elle n'a rien à
voir et d'où le choc sur le court à la
chasse et que c'est quand même cette
inflation importée qui vient percuter de
plein fouet le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages parce que comme ça a été dit
c'est pas la hausse des revenus qui fait
l'inflation c'est la hausse des prix
importés d'où le problème des inégalités
et de ce choc inflationniste qui peut
être très différent sur son situations
on l'a vu entre notamment les zones
rurales très clairement les périurbains
où les agglomérations par exemple la
formation parisienne on avait fait 1-1
petits calculs à l'om c'est eux c'est
que sur l'inflation qui était c'était
mois de mars à mai on avait déjà peu
près 5% d'inflation les 10% des ménages
les mieux lotis entre guillemets face à
ce choc qu'ils avaient une inflation à 2
et demi les 10% des ménages les plus
exposés à une inflation à huit et demi
c'est à dire qu'on avait déjà un écart
très fort et très clairement finalement
dans cette crise là c'est moins la
question des revenus qui va jouer que la
question de votre lieu d'habitation
c'est à dire que au sein même d'un des
cils sonné les plus modestes ou les
classes moyennes vous avez des
situations qui vont être très
différentes nous la difficulté
d'intervention publique c'est à vous
pouvez pas faire juste de l'ajustement
selon la situation du revenu c'est
plutôt la situation du lieu d'habitation
du transport de votre type d'énergie
pour chauffer 2 7 je veux juste être
bref c'est que
comme vous avez vu
l'origine de cette inflation elle est
d'abord et en parlant à des chocs qui
sont très très spécifique c'est à dire
que on a une crise mondiale en 2020
c'est qu'à inédite depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale avec une reprise aussi
inédite qui déstabilisent les économies
avec des problèmes entre la demande qui
remontent très fort des capacités de
production qui ont du mal à suivre on
l'a vu déjà les problèmes
d'approvisionnement existait avant la
guerre en ukraine à la hausse des prix
de l'énergie aussi et puis derrière vous
avez le deuxième choc et la guerre en
ukraine la problématique c'est qu'on
pensait il ya encore quelques mois que
c'était en fait des goulots
d'étranglement c'est à dire qu'on était
face à une situation
de choc économique très particulier avec
une reprise et que ça crée des goulots
d'étranglement et que petit à petit ses
goulets d'étranglement allait
disparaître avec le rétablissement des
capacités de production or en fait là où
pour nous c'est devient extrêmement
compliqué c'est que on n'est peut-être
pas face à quelque chose qui est
temporaire c'est à dire que la guerre en
ukraine conduit probablement à des prix
de l'énergie élevé durablement on sait
pas jusqu'à quand et jusqu'où est toute
la question du gaz 1 vous connaissez le
sujet donc quel est le scénario du prix
de l'énergie c'est quand même
fondamental et puis l'autre point qui
est nouveau aussi c'est les stratégies
adoptées par les pays pour la réponse à
la crise sanitaire serre que compte le
gouvernement fait son projet de loi de
finances en octobre il n'y a pas au
micro au micro on arrive et donc on voit
d'abord l'épidémie est pas forcément
derrière nous et donc ça crée des
nouveaux chocs sur l'économie mondiale
et sur les chaînes de production
mondiale et donc ça crée des tensions en
fait ils disparaissent pas et puis après
c'est la réponse à cette crise sanitaire
c'est là qu'on voit que la chine met en
place une stratégie zéro co vide ce qui
n'est pas le cas de l'europe bon donc du
coup ça ça va entretien attention donc
la grande question fondamentale et puis
je vais peut-être m'arrêter pour la
discussion après
là dessus c'est que à mon avis comme on
l'a vu pour le moment la réponse sur les
salaires elle reste assez modérée on
voit le salaire mensuel de base au
premier trimestre il a augmenté d'un peu
plus de 2% alors qu'on a une inflation
qui était déjà super la 4% nous notre
prévision c'est que ça va faire 3,6 pour
cent sur les salaires mensuels de base
cette année avec une inflation à 5,3
donc en fait ça veut dire que les
salariés perdent emploi d'achat sauf les
personnes au smic ce qui va poser toute
la question de la distribution des
salaires pour les personnes qui sont
juste au dessus du smic le smic en moins
d'un an va augmenter près de 8% à mon
avis ça sera assez peu le cas des
personnes sont 10 20 30 % tu donc c'est
là à la question si sociale qui va
devoir être traité juste peut-être pour
conclure sur un certain nombre de points
pour ouvrir peut-être la suite les
principaux enjeux pour moi bien sûr qui
est déterminant c'est les facteurs
géopolitiques
et l'évolution du prix des hydrocarbures
typiquement les relations avec la russie
et l'approvisionnement en gaz
effectivement si on va sur un schéma où
les prix du pétrole ou du gaz continuent
à augmenter l'inflation continue à
augmenter pour la france il ya aussi un
enjeu qui est important c'est que
effectivement on a eu moins d'inflation
que nos partenaires parce qu'on a eu des
boucliers parce qu'on a eu des remises
de 15 centimes avec un coût budgétaire
qui a été évoquée qui est super à au
pays donc il n'y a pas de mystère on met
plus d'argent en protège mieux etc on
gagne quand même en compétitivité
relative mais ce qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est que du coup quand on va ce
qui peut être assez logique c'est qu'on
peut pas maintenir ces dispositifs et à
maman et qu'on va sortir du bouclier
tarifaire ou des remises de 15 centimes
au faire du ciblage on va réduire la
voilure budgétaire ce qui va créer un
choc inflationniste pour les personnes
qui étaient jusque là protégé donc ce
qui veut dire qu'en 2023 on peut avoir
plus d'inflation que nos partenaires
dans ce cas là ce qui par un effet de
rattrapage
l'autre point qui me semble important
c'est que
c'est effectivement l'incertitude sur
l'évolution de la gestion sanitaire un
ep y voir comment est ce que la chine va
garder de façon durable c'est très
utilisée aux communes qui composent pas
quand même pas mal de problèmes et puis
dernier point il ya la question de
l'épargné qu'il épargne accumulée qui
est considérable pour le moment qui est
pas puisé alors elle va être peut-être
rogné par cette inflation mais pour le
moment elle continue le taux d'épargné
au prêtresse de 8,22 est encore au
dessus de son niveau d'avant crise donc
les ménages sont quand même dans une
phase d'incertitude et d'inquiétude
c'est à dire qu'ils puissent pas dans
leur épargne on ne voit pas ça te départ
le reste élevé et donc s'ils se
mettaient à désépargner ça ferait un
roulant de consommation mais vu
l'incertitude ça me semble assez peu
probable aujourd'hui et puis il ya les
gestion du risque inflationniste par la
bce donc vous avez évoqué un avec ce
fameux lit dilemme entre
augmenter les taux pour montrer qu'il ya
une anticipation sur les risques
inflationnistes et effets de second tour
et que le mandat doit être respectée et
le risque que ça peut générer et
d'autant plus dans une zone euro qui est
cammas et fragile sur cette question là
parce qu'on a toujours ce risque de
fragmentation de la zone euro avec
l'italie qui est plus exposée en cas de
remontée des taux 1 et enfin et ses
fameux
air - angers où j'ai moins m en parler
agnès juste avant qu'ils aient l'écart
entre la croissance et des taux
d'intérêt c'est à dire qu'effectivement
quand votre croissance est plus forte
qu'au taux d'intérêt ça vous permet de
vous désendetter sans faire trop
d'efforts linverse c'est l'effet boule
de neige c'est que votre charge
d'intérêt augmentent plus que votre
recette fiscale donc ça c'est
extrêmement important donc le dilemme
dans un euro il est quand même assez
différent de celui des etats unis c'est
que la remontée des taux aussi créé des
spreads sur des écarts entre pays qui
peut être beaucoup plus fort et dont la
bessée va devoir gérer à l'essence et
elle va mettre un outil anti
fragmentation en place qu'on attend
beaucoup mais le dilemme se rajoute à
toutes ces problématiques mai dernier
point et j'arrête là si on dit qu'il
n'ya pas deux on reste stable sur les
prix de l'énergie mais sinon ça et que
l'on trouve une situation sanitaire à
peu près normale moi je crois qu'on ne
sera pas dans la boucle prix-salaires de
la stagflation des années 70 5 a duré
dix ans d indexation c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui les salaires sont pas
indexés automatiquement la bce a quand
même un mandat très clair à
l'indépendante et les pays sont quand
même très ouvert sur le commerce 1 et en
compétitivité donc ça limite quand même
ses effets de second tour qu'on pouvait
avoir autrefois ce qui veut dire que à
court terme ça fait quand même un choc
négatif aussi sur le prix d'achat et
donc c'est la question sociale à court
terme qui va devoir être traités merci
merci lorsque vous aurez la parole une
deuxième fois vous essaierez de donner
votre peau nue à vous sur une pause si
vous étiez le gouverneur de la banque je
vais la bce qu'est ce que vous feriez
voilà j'aimerais entendre des
symboles mandaw sy ne le refuse et pas
pour quelques instants
monsieur chan et s'il vous plaît pour
une dernière intervention ils vont ainsi
du montagne merci monsieur le président
et
bonjour à tout le monde mesdames et
messieurs alors je représente pas là si
tu montais je tiens à le préciser je
conseille la situe mon talent mêlé vu
que je vais partager avec vous qui sont
plus générale que celle de mes collègues
son personnel je vais d'abord vous
parler de la dimension mondiale de
natation revenir un petit peu sur les
causes de notation vous expliquer
pourquoi je suis un petit peu plus
inquiets à propos de la france que
certains de ses partenaires sur la
possibilité d'une inflation durable et
réfléchir un peu aux moyens que les
politiques publiques peuvent et le tome
10 minutes ce qui va être tout en dix
minutes et un éclairage n'oublierai pas
la bce même si je ne prendrai
certainement pas la casquette de sa
présidence d'abord le retour de
l'inflation c'est vraiment un phénomène
mondial
et d'ailleurs avant avant même que
l'inflation redevienne un sujet de débat
dans le grand public et pour les
politiques c'était un débat chez les
économistes il y avait en gros deux
camps il y avait ceux qui disaient il ya
un excès d pad mondial c'est le saving
lot dont parlait ben bernanke qui est
donc on est condamné à une inflation
très basse et à des taux d'intérêt très
bas pour encore quelques milliers
d'années où quelques vingtaines d'années
quelques dizaines d'années faut pas non
plus exagérer et puis avait ceux qui
disaient oui mais il ya déjà une
certaine accélération de notation aux
états unis nous sommes rentrés dans une
période de
démondialisation alors qu'il n'est pas
brutal mais tous les bénéfices de la
mondialisation qui était de la
désinflation sont inversés et
c'était un débat un peu académique mais
il y avait une chose sur lequel tout le
monde était d'accord parce que beaucoup
de travaux statistiques l'avait prouvé
c'est que l'inflation ces mondiale alors
je citerai une étude qui date de 2010 de
benoit mongeon et de ciccarelli qui
montrait que pour un très grand
échantillon des pays dos et d urée sur
longue période
60% de l'inflation lorsqu'elle monte ou
lorsqu'elle descend c'est une composante
mondiale c'est le cycle économique
mondiale c'est les matières premières
donc l'inflation c'est un point sur
lequel tout le monde était d'accord y
compris ceux qui pensaient qu'ils
avaient un risque qu'ils pensaient
qu'elles n'avaient pas ces mondiale et
c'est bien ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
alors d'où vient à l'inflation qui nous
préoccupe aujourd'hui ben c'est
clairement un choc d'offre c'est
l'incapacité de l'appareil de production
mondiale à suivre la reprise post co
vide qui a été plus forte qu'anticipé
les gens n'ont pas pu dépenser se sont
mis à dépenser et puis un deuxième choc
d'offre qu'il y ait que il y a moins
d'énergie d'énergies fossiles en
particulier produite que prévu et donc
si l'offre est réduite et que la demande
est toujours là on a un choc
inflationniste et qui par définition
doit s'appeler de la stagflation
puisqu'il ya moins d'activités et des
prix plus élevés ça s'appelle de la
station alors j'apprécie ce que mathieu
a dit la stagflation c'est lorsqu'elle
devient endémique que ce devient un
véritable problème est la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui est
véritablement une situation
stagflationniste
alors si c'est un choc d'offre
l'échelle dauphin peut par définition
c'est transitoire parce qu' il y à des
signaux prix qui sont particulièrement
violents regard des prix d'électricité
le prix du gaz etc et s'il ya une chose
qu'on a appris dans l'histoire
économique c'est que les économies en
tout cas les économies de marché elle
s'adapte en 73 ans 79 on a eu des chocs
pétroliers massif quel a été le résultat
une incitation très forte à investir
dans la recherche de pétrole de gaz de
nouvelles techniques d'extraction et en
aval dans des économies beaucoup moins
gourmande en pétrole donc l'offre
s'adapte mais il lui faut du temps et
c'est précisément là où se pose le pro
blême de la possibilité d'un régime
inflationnistes l'offre s'adaptera si ça
lui prend dix ans et bien pendant 10 ans
on a un risque d'inflation si elle est
auto entretenue
le régime d'inflation dont je crois
denis nous a un petit peu parlé en nous
montrant les différentes composantes de
l'inflation et c'est là où j'en viens à
mon troisième point il y a des
particularités en france qui me font
penser que le risque d'une inflation
peut-être plus basse mais plus durable
et significatif en france
il ya deux canaux par lesquels on peut
passer à un régime d'inflation plus
durable le premier ce sont les
anticipations ça c'est bien clair si les
salariés et les patrons pensent que
l'inflation et durable les premiers
demanderont des salaires plus élevés et
les autres sachant qu'ils pourront
augmenter leurs prix auront peu de
raisons de leur résister si en plus
c'est une pénurie de l embauche c'est
une incitation plus en plus à augmenter
les salaires donc ça c'est
l'anticipation les gouvernements ne
peuvent pas grand chose là dessus il ya
des mécanismes sur lequel je reviendrai
l'indexation mais c'est quand même
principalement le rôle des politiques
monétaires de faire en sorte que ce soit
clair pour tout le monde les
consommateurs les salariés les
entreprises nous respecterons notre
objectif de 2% d'inflation qui est
maintenant devenu commun à toutes les
banques centrales dans le monde depuis
que la bce a enfin accepté que ce ne
soit pas 99 mais 2% donc les
anticipations c'est une question de
politique monétaire mais il ya un
deuxième mécanisme qui peut rendre
l'inflation plus durable ce sont les
mécanismes d'indexation alors ils ont
peut-être été réduit par rapport à ce qu
est l indexation de fait lorsque les
économètres gardait la boucle prix
salaires dans les années 70 et 80 mais
nous avons en france pas seulement c'est
aussi le cas de l'italie de l'espagne et
de la belgique là il ya une espèce de
consortium de pays où il y a une forte
indexation des soldats et en france ça
passe quand même essentiellement par le
smic et ceci nous donne un risque
d'inflation auto-entretenue puisque
c'est plus fort en france que ça menée
par exemple en allemagne le risque est
plus élevé alors je fais juste un petit
une petite insert sur la situation
relative de la france et de l'allemagne
la situation de l'allemand et surtout de
l'italie est bien pire que celle de la
france tout simplement parce que leur
dépendance au gaz russe est bien
supérieur donc le choc inflationniste et
le choc sur le pouvoir d'achat sur
l'activité il sera beaucoup plus fort de
ce point de vue là la france si je puis
dire dans une bonne position relative
mais le risque que l'inflation durent
plus longtemps et plus important qu'en
allemagne où il n'y a aucune indexation
des salaires des salaires comme vous le
savez en allemagne sont purement laissé
à la négociation entre les syndicats et
le patronat
quand on a une contrainte d'offres comme
je les décris maintenir le pouvoir
d'achat des salaires c'est très bien
mais ceci veut dire que d'une certaine
manière on entretient une inflation par
un autre biais
si la production ne peut pas augmenter
parce qu a pas de pétrole qui a pas
assez d'électricité pour évoquer des
contraintes que les semi conducteurs
vous n'allez pas les inventer ça ne
pousse pas bien dans les champs et que
vous maintenez le pouvoir d'achat vous
maintenez la demande alors que l'offre
ne peut pas suivre et donc c'est quelque
chose à garder en tête et de tas de
bonnes raisons pour avoir des politiques
de maintien du pouvoir d'achat il faut
avoir en tête que ça fait partie des
mécanismes aussi qu'ils entretiennent
l'inflation en ne permettant pas à la
demande de descendre au niveau de
l'offre alors comment réduire je dirais
pas le choc inflationniste mais plutôt
sa durée donc la première question c'est
est-ce que le gendarme qu'est la banque
centrale européenne est équipé pour ça
est ce qu'elle fait ce qu'il faut
elle nous garantit que l'inflation
restera 2% à moyen long terme alors
c'est très sage de dire moyen long terme
parce que les piques que ce soit
d'inflation d'un fou ou de déflation ne
sont pas des choses sur lesquelles la
politique monétaire peut grand-chose de
plus la politique monétaire ne peut pas
fabriquer d'électricité ou de gaz donc
on trouvera un choc d'offre on comprend
que la banque centrale soit très
prudente avant de se dire ouh là là il
faut que je remonte mais taux d'intérêt
oui mais est elle crédible lorsqu'elle
nous garantit qu'à long terme on restera
à 2% et c'est là où on peut avoir quand
même quelques doutes et la problématique
a été soulignée par mathieu en
particulier il est clair que
la politique quantitative de la banque
centrale européenne dont je rappelle que
le but était de faire baisser les taux
d'intérêt à long terme donc de stimuler
la demande en espérant que ça ferait
remonter l'inflation c'était l'idée
cette politique quantitative est
terminée puisque on ne cherche pas
maintenant à faire baisser l'inflation
or cette politique quantitative il faut
appeler un chat un chat c'est ce qui a
complètement annulé le risque de crédit
de pays plus faibles et quand on dit
pays plus faibles bien c'est une espèce
de cache sexe pour parler de l'italie
donc la prime de crédit que les
investisseurs qui sont les épargnants
normalement demande lorsqu'ils ont des
doutes sur une économie a été totalement
éradiquée par la politique quantitative
de la bce pendant plusieurs années
toutes les émissions du trésor
italiennes étaient achetés quasiment
directement par la banque centrale
européenne donc le marché était
incapable de donner un prix à ce risque
de crédit
tout ceci est terminé
la politique quand est il n'a plus aucun
sens puisque l'inflation est là et donc
le risque de crédit réapparaît avec le
risque d' anticipations
autoréalisatrices si les marchés vont
trop loin c'est à dire que la situation
devient de pire en pire et que le risque
de crédit qui était peut-être des petits
au départ pourraient devenir beaucoup
plus important et donc vraiment le
dilemme est très compliqué pour la
banque centrale européenne ce qui est
pas du tout le cas de la fed de la
banque du japon ou la banque
d'angleterre c'est à dire que politique
quantative s'est terminée donc je ne
peut plus cacher le risque de crédit de
l'italie et de quelques autres pays
j'espère que la france n'en fera pas
partie d'un autre côté il faut quand
même que je remonte un peu mais taux
d'intérêt pour m'assurer que tout le
monde a bien compris c'est 2% à long
terme oui mais le faisan j'aggrave la
situation
donc la bce nous dit mais nous on est
des gens très astucieux on va inventer
on va dire je crois que ça a présenté
cet après midi peut-être que certains
d'entre nous connaissent déjà le nom de
l'instrument on aura un instrument pour
empêcher la fragmentation c'est à dire
ce que ce risque de crédit sur l'italie
et quelques autres pays deviennent trop
importants pour que la zone euro reste
gérable et en même temps on lutte contre
l'inflation je peux vous dire qu'il
risque d'y avoir un certain scepticisme
il faut être
il faut écouter ce que la bce va nous
dire mais il y a quand même un risque de
crédibilité donc sur cette question de
l'ancrage des anticipations d'inflation
le gendarme n'est pas forcément le plus
crédible qu'on puisse imaginer
alors il ya un deuxième élément je
voudrais signaler sur le traitement de
l'inflation et qui ne dépend pas
directement des politiques économiques
c'est la conjoncture est ce que la
conjoncture pourrait régler notre
problème
s'il ya une récession
les récessions ses larmes anti-inflation
ultime si je puis dire ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas mais ça risquerait
de l'être hors de mon point de vue je ne
suis plus un conjoncturistes qui est
vraiment les mains dans le cambouis mais
je n'ai été suffisamment longtemps pour
faire attention à tous les signaux qui
viennent des enquêtes de conjoncture et
pas seulement en france mais aux états
unis et je vois que les anticipations
des entreprises c'est très clair en
allemagne mais c'est clair en france
aussi les c'est clair aux états unis
depuis trois mois sont en train de
dégringoler il ya de bonnes raisons pour
ça il ya ce choc d'offre est extrêmement
important il ya là risque de pénurie
d'énergie et il y a ce n'a pas encore
été mentionné mais c'est extrêmement
important une forte dégradation des
conditions financières de financement
des économies et du secteur privé
essentiellement la chute du marché
d'actions 7 17% depuis le début de
l'année pour le s p 500 pour l'indicé
américain un peu moins pour le cac 40
l'euro s'est déprécié
mais surtout l'écartement des spreads de
crédit à ce qu'on appelle les spreads de
crédit c'est ce que doivent payer en
termes de taux d'intérêt en plus les
entreprises par rapport aux états qui
eux peuvent toujours un taxer leurs
leurs contribuables et renouveler leurs
dettes ce qui n'est pas le cas des
entreprises or les spreads de crédit ces
cartes énormément ce qui est tout à fait
normal puisqu'il ya un renversement des
politiques monétaires donc le
financement des entreprises que ce soit
par le marché des actions que ce soit
par le marché obligataire et
progressivement parce qu'elles
s'alignent par les banques devient plus
difficile quand il ya un resserrement
des conditions financières qui lie à un
choc d'offre qu'on vous dit et à juste
titre qu'il risque d'y avoir des
pénuries il est normal que les
entreprises se dit ça risque de mal se
passer moi il me semble que la
probabilité d'une récession
aux états unis et en europe je me
prononcerai pas pour la chine
puisqu'elle était déjà en récession au
deuxième trimestre et que ça dépend
beaucoup de leurs politiques mais en
tout cas pour ces deux zones absolument
essentiel pour les prix en général cette
probabilité d'une récession disons à
l'horizon de six mois est assez
importante
6,7
ce résultat qui n'est quand même pas
souhaitable se réalise les prix des
matières premières baissent les
anticipations d'inflation aux etats-unis
sont déjà en chute libre parce que les
marchés anticipent une récession donc
les prix des matières premières baissent
et lorsque vous avez une récession et
bien il y a moins d'incitations à avoir
des revendications salariales puisque la
préservation de l'emploi devient plus
importante donc évidemment je ne
souhaite pas que ce soit une récession
qui règlent notre problème mais je vous
signale que ça fait partie des choses
qui sont peut-être dans les cartes alors
est ce qu'il y a quand même des moyens
positif bien entendu qu'il y en a limité
le risque d'inflation salariale donc ça
c'est très important pour éviter
l'enclenchement de la boucle
prix-salaires peut se faire en réduisant
temporairement les charges salariales ce
que les salariés ce qui intéresse les
salariés c'est l'épaule coût du travail
c'est le salaire qu'ils reçoivent par
contre les entreprises elles fixeront
leur salaire plutôt par rapport au coût
salarial et donc si temporairement je
crois que c'est la voie qui est choisie
par l'allemagne ont réduit les charges
ceci permet de préserver le salaire qui
est directement perçue sans que le coût
du travail augmente et donc sans
déclencher cette dynamique alors
évidemment il ya un défaut mais qui est
toujours le même si on cherche à
préserver le pouvoir d'achat eh bien on
maintient la demande alors que l'offre
de la peine à suivre il n'y a pas de
politique de pouvoir d'achat qui
n'encourt pas cette critique donc il
faut faire avec la deuxième façon de
procéder c'est celle qui est largement
employés par quasiment tous les pays
mais en france encore plus qu'ailleurs
c'est limiter l'augmentation des prix de
l'énergie et ça c'est une politique
intelligente parce que justement elle
lui le risque d'accélération des
salaires et donc d'inflation qui devient
plus auto-entretenue elle a deux défauts
mais à nouveau on ne peut pas avoir le
beurre l'argent du beurre et le sourire
de la crémière le premier c'est que ça
maintient une demande pour des produits
énergétiques dont l'offre est réduite le
deuxième c'est que ça a un impact sur
les finances publiques mais là agnès
benassy on a parfaitement bien parler
alors il ya un troisième point que je
voudrais signaler dans les politiques
qui peuvent aider c'est de réduire la
demande de produits énergétiques parce
que c'est quand même notre problème
numéro un et il y a des propositions qui
sont faites par l' agence internationale
de l'énergie qui ont été publiés là
quelques jours cinq points tous est
exprimé dans un langage très
diplomatique bien entendu mais en gros
ça nous dit il est temps de penser au
rationnement il est temps de penser à ou
va-t-on réduire d'une manière peut-être
autorités à la demande quand ya un
déséquilibre offre demande en gros ça ne
se résout que de deux façons qui ne sont
pas d'ailleurs contradictoires la
première c'est les prix si ça devient
très cher les gens achètent moins la
deuxième c'est à dire bah désolé voilà
vous aurez droit à telle quantité que ce
soit pour les industriels que ce soit
pour les ménages l'allemagne a choisi
cette solution là et je crois comprendre
qu'elle est déjà même assez bien avancé
pour l'explicitation de plan de
rationnement nous ne sommes pas en
france dans une situation aussi
difficile parce que nous avons une offre
d'énergie qui est beaucoup plus
diversifiée et qui dépend moins du gaz
russe mais il me semble qu'il faut dire
les choses aujourd'hui commencer à
travailler sur des politiques de
rationnement ce serait de la bonne
politique y compris pour limiter
l'inflation le point commun de tous que
j'ai sauté c'est que ça va aller vers là
qu'on va aller vers la conclusion
temporaire
horaires justement ma conclusion c'est
qu'il y à des politiques qui ne sont pas
temporaires si on a un problème d'offre
et les meilleures politiques c'est
d'augmenter l'offre et en particulier
l'offre d'énergies non carbonées bien
entendu alors c'est évidemment des
politiques de moyen long terme mais
c'est pas parce que c'est du moyen long
terme que ça ne vaut pas le coup de les
mettre en oeuvre immédiatement car des
chocs d'offre nous en avons un qe massif
qui est multidimensionnelle aujourd'hui
mais rien n'est exclu qu'il y en ait
d'autres dans le futur donc travaillant
tout de suite sur le long terme excusez
moi d'avoir et faire un tout petit peu
trop l'eau monsieur le président
l'inflation telle qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui
n'obéit pas tout à fait aux canons de ce
qu'on a pu nous enseigner il ya encore
quelques années
je partage assez les chiffres que vous
avez donnée sur l'origine alors c'est
évidemment principalement le la question
des énergies
dont je rappelle que le coût
pour la direction du trésor je pense que
c'est important le coût de l'énergie
pèse relativement lourd dans le déficit
budgétaire elle d'un déficit commercial
de la france
il fut un temps c'est un peu plus de 50%
là on est autour de 40 à 38 40 % donc eu
dans les orientations
que les pouvoirs publics l'exécutif
est peut-être le parlement aura à
prendre il ya sur ce sujet une pré
orientation alors jeu j'ai bien entendu
le présent république faire un virage à
180 degrés
par rapport au nucléaire je crois qu'il
n'y a pas que ça ce qui m'amène qui aime
à dire que il ya eu je pense des
décisions des choix malheureux qu'on va
porter pendant un certain temps et vous
parler effectivement d'énergie
décarbonée
voilà il ya vraiment de la difficulté
et beaucoup de travail devant nous moi
je voulais revenir alors je voulais
poser la question sur est ce que les uns
les autres vous pensez que cette
inflation va être durable deux d'entre
vous ont déjà répondu
donc je maintiens néanmoins la question
peut-être plus pour madame bénassy quéré
et puis je veux revenir sur l'objet de
cette table ronde s'est essayé de
comprendre
avec les phénomène inflationniste
actuelle les conséquences sur le pouvoir
d'achat et à l'aune des mesures
proposées par étapes par le gouvernement
avec une nouvelle étape parce que
simplement sans fin c'est pas un tour de
france mais ça y ressemble il ya même je
ne pense que parfois il ya des
contradictions il ya des manques de
ciblage moi je pense effectivement que
vous avez évoquées plus tôt la france
rurale et puis parfois également les
contraintes
en milieu en milieu urbain et également
sur les plus basses rémunérations donc
par rapport à tout ça et avec les
mesures qui sont annoncées aujourd'hui
il n'y at il pas une forme de confusion
si je prends la prime exceptionnelle de
pouvoir d'achat qui devrait devenir la
prime
de protection de la valeur le partage de
la valeur oui
moi j'ai des sentiments qu'elle 2 elle
s'annonçait temporaire m 2 pourrait
devenir pérenne
d'ailleurs dans le fractionnement ça
veut dire qu'il y aurait un nouveau
dispositif
si on est pour combattre et s'il
combattre un pic d'inflation et de
maintien pouvoir d'achat ça devrait donc
être temporaire donc comment les mesures
obéissent
selon vous est-ce qu'elle réponde bien à
ce phénomène qui était espéré comme
temporaire parce que si on répond de
manière temporaire un phénomène plus
durable on risque de frapper à côté de
la cible et donc de désorienter nos
concitoyens et puis dernier élément est
peut-être pour nous en commission des
finances le plus important c'est tout ça
a pris tout ça un coup
un coût très lourd pour nos finances
publiques
comment pensez vous que l'on puisse
répondre de la meilleure des manières
sur l'impact budgétaire la dégradation
de la plupart de nos agrégats budgétaire
et de finances publiques et puisqu'on
est au sénat j'ajoute que comme le
prétend un public avait annoncé m
comment dirais-je une réduction
supplémentaire de 10 milliards
sur les moyens accordés par l'état aux
collectivités locales quand celle ci
on fait face à cette période sans
dégradation de leurs ratios comment est
ce que vous imaginez la suisse est à
dire éviter une dégradation
peut être importante j'espère pas funès
de notre économie et de notre évidemment
de nos ratios budgétaires d'abord la
question des difficultés de recrutement
va me permettre d'insister sur le côté
choc tough en vous parlant de l' enquête
trimestrielle de l'insee qui est très
ancienne elle date des années 70
depuis 1990 elle pose aussi une question
sur les difficultés de recrutement et
lorsqu'on regarde les résultats de cette
enquête depuis 1970 donc là je vous
parle vraiment de longue période il y a
deux pourcentages de répondants qui font
crevé tous les plafonds c'est celui sur
l'incapacité à produire plus en raison
de difficultés de goulots de production
et ceci par exemple la pénurie de semi
conducteurs en fait partie des goulots
de production qui est en amont pour les
entreprises on n'a jamais été aussi haut
en terme d'écart type on est un petit
peu denses que ceux dont denis ferrand
parlait mais c'est quand même très
frappant que c'est le plus haut
historique mans et pour les difficultés
de recrutement ou la question n'est
posée que depuis 1990 on n'a jamais été
aussi haut donc nous avons bien affaire
en france je parle pas d'une enquête
faite aux états unis à un choc d'offre
dans la mule norme dans le sens où les
entreprises alors il s'agit surtout du
secteur industriel mais c'est important
pour l'inflation puisqu'elle est
beaucoup concentrée sur des biens ne
peuvent pas produire plus et donc le
paradoxe dont vous parlez monsieur
sénateurs de stimuler la demande alors
que c'est l'offre qui est contrainte et
il est évident alors ma réponse quand
même à votre question c'est que ça a un
sens ça a un sens si ça permet de
limiter les enchaînements
inflationnistes suivant donc des
politiques dont le but ne serait pas de
stimuler la demande ce qui est absurde
quand on a un choc d'offre mais de faire
en sorte que les enchaînements salariaux
soit modérée est une politique que je
trouve pertinente parce qu'elles pensent
moyen long terme bon des puits se trouve
que leurs yeux elle répond aussi mais ça
c'est une question qui est beaucoup plus
politique à des impératifs politiques de
court terme donc il y a quand même un
certain sens à faire cette chose absurde
qui consiste à soutenir la demande à
condition que ce soit préemptant portr
deuxièmement que ça vise à réduire les
enchaînements salariaux ce qui me fait
répondre à la question comment est-ce
qu'on finance les baisses de charge par
le déficit budgétaire n'y a pas d'autre
moyen mais je répète le point crucial
c'est temporaire on voit bien la
difficulté politique c'est quand on fait
quelque chose de temporaire tout le
monde voudrait ensuite que ce soit
permanent
deuxième point sur lequel il faut
vraiment insister c'est la situation
extraordinairement difficile de l'italie
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
s'annoncent mal pour l'ensemble de la
zone euro c'est un cauchemar pour
l'italie avant tout mais aussi pour la
banque centrale européenne en plus du
fait que la croissance en italie nuls
depuis très longtemps donc quand on se
plaint des gains de productivité en
france c'est une affaire qui est très
ancienne en italie et c'est la raison
principale pour laquelle les marchés
sont inquiets politique budgétaire
italienne elle a toujours été restrictif
n'a pas toujours bien entendu mais les
réceptifs depuis très longtemps mais
quand ya pas de croissance on peut se
poser la question comment allait
rembourser allez vous rembourser votre
dette d'ailleurs c'est la bce qui achète
votre dette d'habitude donc l'italie est
dans une situation fragile ancienne mais
se conjugue le choc qu'ovide qui touche
quand même et vente fin d'une manière
particulièrement importante du site
touristique qui est importante pour
l'italie et deuxièmement le choc
énergétique excusez moi du peu ça nous
fait trois chocs pour l'italie et donc
les réponses que la bce va nous donner
aujourd'hui sur son outil anti
fragmentation sont importants mais je
pense qu'il faut se dire d'avant ce
qu'il y a que le risque italien a
augmenté avec ses crises l'italie
bénéficient de transfert l'union
européenne ça pourrait ne pas être
suffisant sa dot est sur nos radars
troisième sujet est-ce qu'il faut
mobiliser l'épargné excédentaire dont
denis du rhône dont denis ferrand nous a
expliqué qu'elle était déjà à 40 ou 50%
rogné par l'inflation mais ça fait quand
même 50 % qui restent alors moi je
dirais que si c'est la mobiliser pour ça
et à la consommation mais il faut pas le
faire puisque on a une contrainte
d'offres donc pousser les gens à plus
consommée aujourd'hui ça fait de
l'inflation plus qu'autre chose en
revanche fait en sorte que cette épargne
puisse aller vers des investissements
donc c'est une autre manière de soutenir
l'économie ce n'est pas l'enchaînement
habituel pouvoir d'achat consommation
emplois non pas du tout si ça va vers de
l'investissement et que cet
investissement permet d'augmenter
l'offre à long terme de choses dont nous
manquons comme l'énergie décarbonée et
bien c'est évidemment une chose qui me
paraît très intelligente euro-dollar et
politique monétaire américaine ça c'est
assez crucial la politique monétaire
américaine a été en retard sur
l'évolution de l'inflation aux états
unis qui je le rappelle avait commencé
par une accélération des coûts salariaux
avant la crise qu vide donc c'était déjà
une économie au plein emploi ont
commencé à avoir accéléré la fed est
restée si je puis dire un petit peu de
côté jusqu'à que les chiffres
d'inflation est le fait qu'elle soit
assez généralisé aux états unis les
obliger à réagir ben bernanke qui a
reconnu même s'il ne fait plus partie
les solidaires que oui on a été trop
long à réagir et donc on va pas se
plaindre du fait que la fed réagisse
contre l'inflation américaine je
rappelle que l'inflation ces mondiale et
que si on a de la façon de aux états
unis on a une inflation partout alors
évidemment il ya un jeu non coopératif
par définition des politiques monétaire
en relevant ses taux d'intérêt la fête
contribue à faire monter le dollar dont
la principale dans raison pour laquelle
ils montent c'est l'augmentation du prix
du pétrole ce n'est pas la politique
monétaire lorsque le prix du pétrole
augmente il y un recyclage des pétro de
la moins important que dans les années
70 qui va vers des actifs américains
donc plus de demandes de dollars et en
plus ce qui fait une grande différence
avec les années 70 les états unis
maintenant son ex horta turn est
d'énergie en particulier grâce au gaz de
schiste donc ces deux facteurs
expliquent l'essentiel de la hausse du
dollar vient s'y rajouter la politique
monétaire donc de mon point de vue c'est
patent l'euro qui est faible c'est un
dollar qui est hyper fort contre toute
monnaie alors je signale en passant on
n'en a pas parlé mais que ceci pose un
grave problème pour le crédit d'un grand
nombre de pays émergents les spreads de
crédit dont je parlais pour les
entreprises sont en train de s'écarter
de manière très importante pour des pays
qui dépendent beaucoup de la politique
monétaire américaine mais qui ne sont
pas directement concerné par les
décisions la fed ne prend pas cette
décision pour la zone dollar donc nous
nous sommes si je puis dire dans la zone
euro victimes collatérales la seule
manière qui pourrait
compenser en partie cette politique
monétaire américaine ce serait d'avoir
une politique monétaire équivalente mais
on a tous compris je viens de rappeler
la situation italienne que les dégâts
seraient encore pire que l' avantage qui
durait avoir une monnaie plus forte donc
je pense que ceci doit on doit
l'accepter si il y à récession les
mécanismes sur le dollar s'inverse les
anticipations sur les taux d'intérêts
s'inverse le prix du pétrole baissent
donc le dollar baisse donc ne nous
préoccupons pas trop de cette baisse de
l'euro par rapport de là c'est quelque
chose qui est transitoire
j'en reste là monsieur président bien et
vous avez fixé la maille pour les autres
dont mathieu plane va bénéficier de sept
minutes 7 minutes ah oui ok
[Musique]
du coup bon il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
questions c'est merci en tout cas ça
soulève quand même pas mal
d'interrogations et on va essayer
d'apporter quelques réponses
en quelques minutes sur le choc d'offre
négatif je partage en partie en fait le
diagnostic
parce qu'il ya deux chocs d'offre en
fait dans cette affaire il ya quand même
un choc d'offre sur les matières
premières qui est pas le même que sur
les produits industriels or
sap a les mêmes effets y compris sur
notre balance commerciale et les
réponses qu'on peut donner à ce choc
d'offre négatif dans un cas on voit bien
qu'on a un problème de politique
industrielle
avec les approvisionnements enfin qu'on
va pas régler du jour au lendemain mais
qu'on connaît depuis un certain temps
avec les déficits commerciaux qu'on a
évoqué donc ça pose la question de
comment être plus performant d'un point
de vue industriel et quelles sont les
politiques à mener dans l'autre cas le
choc d'offre négatif lié à au fait que
la russie pourrait si vivement écarté du
marché mondial des hydrocarbures pose
beaucoup de questions et les effets
notamment sur la demande sachant que
bien sûr on va pas produire ces
hydrocarbures et que même substitué ces
hydrocarbures par d'autres types
d'énergie qui sont non fossiles pose
beaucoup de questions et c'est des
enjeux de moyen long terme
donc ça pose d'abord la question de
comment on répond à ce choc sur
l'énergie
quel est son impact
sur les ménages et sur les entreprises
et comment on essaye d'accélérer
j'allais dire peut-être le point positif
de cette crise est peut-être d'accélérer
la transition en tout cas elle serait
trouvé des solutions pour avoir une à
mix énergétique plus décarbonés et
éventuellement trouver des voies vers
une consommation on va dire un peu plus
efficace
mais dans le court terme on sait que
l'énergie est assez peu substituables
même si vous faites un peu de sobriété
si vous essayez de d'instruire un peu de
télétravail ou de covoiturage
pour beaucoup et on l'a dit le problème
c'est que c'est un choc aussi assez
différent selon les types de ménages
entre le cadre parisien dans un
appartement effectivement la classe
moyenne en zone rurale qui a deux
véhicules avec un logement peut-être
assez mal isolé le choc et n'a rien à
voir donc le problème c'est que c'est
aussi la difficulté d'accompagner le
changement est l'impact à court terme
social quoi c'est à dire on voit que
si un bien et peu substituables c'est
directement le reste à vivre qui diminue
et là vous êtes aussi face à autre chose
c'est comment on répartit en fait ce
choc inflationniste est à dire qui prend
en charge le choc inflationniste l'état
en fait en réalité a fait relativement
beaucoup j'allais dire par rapport à ce
qu'on a vu ailleurs c'est pour ça que ça
coûte cher et que ça a été possible et
dans un premier temps
la question maintenant c'est dire si le
choc finalement epa transitoire on peut
pas maintenir des dispositifs aussi
large et donc il faut les cibler et on
voit que plus on va aller dans le détail
et puis on va essayer de cibler plus est
délicat et plus ça va faire des perdants
et vous les essayer de garder un signal
prix c'est-à-dire dire en sorte il n'y a
pas forcément de raison de mettre un
prix de l'énergie un niveau bas alors
qu'ils coupent le niveau du prix mondial
est très élevé ou alors ça coûte très
cher donc sait où est ce que vous faites
ce ciblage or c'est vrai que j'ai
l'impression que le ciblage il va être
relativement baril va couvrir on va dire
au smic voire un peu au dessus donc ça
va poser toute la question
j'allais dire des personnes qui sont
allées à 1,2 point 5 smic
dont et sa l'état n'y peut rien mais on
voit bien que la réponse ou si des
emplois peut être très différente sur le
salaire c'est à dire on a à d et des
ch'ti c'est nous c'est un demi enfin en
gros c'est 0,5 cercle contre l'inflation
augmente comme ça 2 1 pour cent les
salaires augmentent de 0,5 en fait dans
un premier temps mais la situation peut
être très différente selon les
situations individuelles et donc
certaines entreprises ont des marges de
manoeuvre pour augmenter les salaires et
d'autres beaucoup moins ce qui n'est pas
le cas par exemple des retraités qui
vont voir et assez logiquement leur
retraite augmenter ou les personne au
smic ont une garantie de poura d'achat
donc la question qui va être fondamental
c'est pour les personnes qui sont en
emploi qui sont au dessus du smic
principalement et dont l'employeur qui
sont dans des pme n'ont pas forcément
les marges de manoeuvre pour les
augmenter et cela il passe en fait
les mailles du filet j'ai l'impression
et ça ça va être assez difficile
d'expliquer qu' ils se sont un peu les
perdants de cette crise là donc voilà
donc je dis pas que j'ai pas de réponse
est très claire là dessus mais ça ça
pose vraiment cette question de ce choc
d'offre et comment on essaie
d'accompagner ce choc d'offre aussi d'un
point de vue social parce que c'est un
des impacts sur le pouvoir d'achat
sur tout autre point l'épargné accumulée
elle est considérable on parle de 170
milliards depuis le début de la crise
mais forcément c'est pareil elle et ne
pas accumuler de la même façon en gros
80% de cette épargne est détenu par les
25 % des ménages en haut de l'échelle
des revenus ce qui est assez logique au
regard des choses donc c'est vrai que
c'est pareil si vous cumulez
le choc macroéconomique et ces chocs
individuel on a des choses très très
différente c'est à dire entre des
ménages qui ont écumé de l'épave qui
sont moins exposées à ce choc etc ont
décapé c'est de réagir et ceux qui ont
déjà mangé leur épargne et qui se
retrouvent avec un choc très négatif
donc j'allais dire le problème c'est
qu'on a un choc macroéconomique et donc
on parle de risque de récession
moi je serai un peu moins dur enfin je
pense que bien sûr que le réseau
récession est évident mais je pense
qu'ils dépendent beaucoup ce qui va se
passer dans les mois à venir avec la
avec la russie l'approvisionnement du
gaz russe qui sera mon avis assez
déterminant mais on a aussi un choc
microéconomiques et c'est là la
difficulté des points public sait
comment vous répondez à des chocs micro
pour les entreprises pour les ménages
vous n'avez pas faire de vous avez pas
traiter 30 millions de cas et donc
forcément vous allez avoir des effets de
seuil vous allez avoir aidé des
problèmes et en même temps vous avez une
question budgétaire il faut être
raisonnable aussi sévère qu'on voit bien
qu'on a déjà eu un choc obid qui a été
massif on a près 200 milliards d'euros
d'un de d'impulsion budgétaires qui ont
été mis
et donc on ne peut pas continuer
indéfiniment comme ça où un moment donné
va se poser la question du financement
surtout avec la remontée des taux dont
on a parlé si les taux remontent et que
notre croissance diminue ça va poser
quelques difficultés donc une récession
ça pose aussi ses difficultés là c'est
que une récession c'est aussi moins de
recettes fiscales donc vous êtes face à
ce problème à et
du cou
bon je termine peut-être là-dessus
un point important aussi et c'est pour
ça je veux pas envoyer trop de signaux
négatifs mais
quelque part j'ai à dire nous enfin en
tant que macro game list on a une une
interrogation forte c'est comment ça se
fait qu'on créé autant d'emplois et
c'est plutôt une bonne chose pour le
marché du travail mais on reconnaît il
ya toujours le revers de la médaille
c'est que le revers de médaille c'est
que la productivité a baissé depuis 2000
19 ski aussi historique c'est à dire que
pour produire la même chose on a besoin
de plus d'emplois vous regardez la
valeur ajoutée aujourd'hui du secteur
privé au même niveau que la valeur
ajoutée de fin 2019 donc on réalise la
même valeur ajoutée d'un produit ma
technique on a sept cent mille emplois
en plus donc 3 % d'emplois en plus on a
besoin de 3 % d'emplois en plus pour
produire la même chose ce qui pose la
question effectivement des marges de
manoeuvre y compris des entreprises pour
augmenter les salaires dans ce cadre-là
tiers que soit il ya un peu de
croissance elles vont faire de la
productivité mais elles vont détruire
des emplois soit augmente les salaires
dans ce cadre là et ça va poser beaucoup
de questions sur leur compétitivité donc
c'est vrai que l'équation est
malheureusement assez assez dur surtout
dans un monde où on va devoir accélérer
la transition ou une inflation qui peut
être un peu plus robuste le problème des
déficits et un ralentissement de la
croissance donc les enjeux j'allais dire
je crois que nous le maire le disait
plus dur est devant nous et je veux bien
croire que c'est en partie vrai qu'on
bon ça nous aide tout ça merci à mathieu
plane d'avoir dit votre absence de
solution denis ferrand va demander
ferrand pardon et vous on va vous
remettre à votre place madame vous allez
conclure traditionnel nationalement nous
nous laissons plutôt la direction du
trésor conclure voyez ce président juste
avant louis ne la parle vous voulez
venir un mot sur la productivité ça vous
aurait tout inventé monsieur alors
allons-y à titre exceptionnel
c'est pour mettre un bémol à ce constat
qui est fait par
ainsi monsieur plane de la baisse de la
productivité quatre sont forts
ralentissements
une des raisons quand même très
importante est une très bonne raison
c'est que les réformes du marché du
travail font qu'aujourd'hui sont
employées en france quand des gens qui
ont une plus faible productivité que le
pool de ceux qui étaient employées
auparavant
si on fait des réformes du marché du
travail je me félicite qu'elle est
réussie on a réussi à faire baisser le
taux de chômage à 7% pas de crier
locascio pas de pause s'achever il a
fait inévitablement baisser la
productivité avant ses réformes du
marché du travail je disais aux gens qui
me posaient des questions je saurai si
ça marche si la productivité baisse donc
ce n'est pas en soi une mauvaise
nouvelle la productivité structurelles
c'est beaucoup plus important et ça
c'est une question d'innovation est ce
que nous innovons assez en france je
crains que non mais cet effet de
productivité qui tient à la composition
de la force de travail on va quand même
pas le regretter moi pas regretter que
des gens puissent travailler aujourd'hui
en france alors qu'auparavant ils ne
pouvaient pas travailler
je préfère la conclusion alors de vie de
différents rapports pour compléter sur
ce point parce qu'effectivement ça
faisait partie des éléments que je
voulais évoquer revenir sur l'enjeu de
productivité qui est vraiment
déterminant sur les évolutions des
salaires je crois plus à la
détermination de la productivité vers
les salaires que des salaires vers la
productivité donc la théorie du crr
déficiences je crois que quand même plus
que celle la productivité qui détermine
notre dans un premier temps le les
salaires sur la productivité il ya aussi
un élément qu'est alors il je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec l'observation que
vient de faire éric il faut regarder que
sur les taux d'emploi qui ont le plus
bouger récemment c'est le taux d'emploi
des plus jeunes et ça c'est l'impact
notamment d'abba des politiques de
développement de de l'apprentissage de
l'alternance on à 4,5 points de taux
d'emploi en plus pour les pour les 16 24
ans par rapport à la situation de 2019
et il n'y a aucun autre pays européen
qui a le plus augmenté selon taux
d'emploi des 15 24 sur la période
récente et ça c'est un effet de
composition sur la productivité
deuxième élément de composition qui est
tout à fait remarquable sur la période
récente pour expliquer le ralentissement
de la productivité ce sont les pratiques
de rétention de manoeuvre dans les dents
les entreprises et en particulier dans
l'industrie
depuis 2019 la productivité de
l'industrie est négative alors que c'est
le secteur quand bien même on sait que
l'industrie a un poids dans le pipe qui
est quand même assez faible en france
relativement à la zone euro et c'est une
litote que de le dire et bien lundi si
grosso modo elle produit entre 40 et 50
% des gains de productivité de
l'ensemble de l'économie or depuis trois
ans la productivité afin de la valeur
ajoutée a moins progressé que ne l'a
fait l'an pendant l'industrie donc la
productivité a reculé et là c'est
vraiment les politiques de rétention de
main d'oeuvre je sais que j'ai des
difficultés de recrutement très aigu et
bien ou plus au premier retournement
conjoncturel venu là je vais essayer de
préserver le plus longtemps possible
mais salariés en place parce que je sais
que j'aurai du mal à les retrouver au
moment du redémarrage de l'activité et
ça c'est vrai que c'est un des effets
assez fort delà des difficultés de
recrutement je vais passer en revue
quelques quelques points effectivement
sur l'assuré panne cela a été évoqué par
mathieu à l'instant je crois que c'est
dès le mois de mars que le cee avait dit
que en gros l'assuré panne des deux
premiers déciles avait été lessivés donc
alors maintenant je ne sais plus
jusqu'où c'est en train de remonter mais
probablement qu'on n'aurait pas loin du
5/6 des cils désormais dont l'assuré par
n'y aura pas disparu mais je n'ai aucun
élément pour là c'est juste un jugement
c'est juste un sentiment ya plus qu
autre chose sur le caractère durable de
l'inflation effectivement je ne me suis
pas prononcé là dessus il y à un point
ça a été évoqué par paris x et qu'elle
ait été a repris aussi par plusieurs
d'entre vous on n'avait pas parlé dans
nos présentations du taux de change
parce que le taux de change en fait
vient donner une deuxième étape
peut-être à l'inflation importée c'était
une inflation importée est président et
m venaient principalement des cours des
matières premières effectivement les
matières premières reculent pour ce
moment et c'est très fort sur sur les
métaux c'est aussi une bonne
illustration de ce qu'il ya un risque
d'inflation de récession qui est
croissante devant nous mais désormais
l'inflation d'importer ne peut être
changé de nature dans le sens où elle
proviendra un peu plus du comportement
de l'euro contre le dollar quand bien
même je suis d'accord il a on ne voit
pas ce se dégrader encore bien enfin se
déprécier encore bien plus longtemps
parce que les écarts de taux d'intérêt
vont progressivement se resserrer sur le
sur le revenu disponible brut
en fait le graphique que j'avais montré
que vous aviez sur lesquels vous êtes
revenu monsieur le sénateur c'était un
graphique sur qui essaie de réconcilier
le message des économistes les
économistes android et 10 mai il n'y a
pas de problème de pouvoir d'achat prix
à l'échelle macroéconomique et c'est
vrai qu'on a une progression sur dix ans
de 10% du pouvoir d'achat du revenu
disponible brut alors ça c'est peut-être
pas assez je sais pas mais ça c'est une
affaire de d'appréciation mais quand on
le regarde ensuite au niveau du ressenti
le ressenti il est exprimé par un ménage
or quand le reçu quand on va corriger le
revenu disponible par la composante
démographique par la composante
également sociologique faut se rappeler
que le nombre de ménages progresse deux
fois plus vite que ne le fait la
population alors on se rend compte qu'il
n'y a pas de progression du pouvoir
d'achat et pas seulement sur les trois
dernières années mais également depuis
2010 donc il y à bien il y à bien une
mesure par qui a utilisé par les
économistes qui dit d'avis qu'il est
pouvoir d'achat qui est distribué mais
le ressenti individuelle du fait de ces
évolutions démographiques et
sociologiques n'est pas n'est pas au
rendez vous donc j'ai essayé de
réconcilier les les deux appréciations
sur sur l'aspect des minima sociaux
qu'ils étaient évoqués par didier
rambaud je ne sais pas combien de
salariés sont concernés je crois que
c'est assez peu il ya très peu de
salariés qui se trouvent aux minima de
branche et surtout quand ils passent en
dessous du smic parce que toute façon
c'est la règle du smic qui va s'imposer
alors sur les ya pas de deux mécanismes
automatiques qui induisent dès lors
qu'ils y aillent dès lors que le smic
était pas ce minima sociaux ya pas de
mécanisme automatique qui fait une
renégociation de lapins des dents dans
les branches tout se passe dans le cadre
des nao des négociations annuelles
obligatoires qui en général se tiennent
plutôt en fin d'exercice ou début
d'exercice et qui était en fait calées
sur de facto sur le rythme d'évolution
du smic là on est sur une assure une
période qui est très particulière qui
tient ce qu'il y à des rondes et
relèvement du smic qui interviennent en
cours d'année et donc la plupart enfin
beaucoup de branches ayant mis en criant
mis en place des clauses de revoyure
année on va avoir des renégociations qui
vont se faire mais la proportion de
personnes concernées est relativement
faible après le nombre de smicards c'est
je crois aux environs de 12 % des
salariés est toute la question est de
savoir comment ça va se déplacer la
hausse du smic vers les personnes qui
sont situés un peu au dessus du smic est
ce qu'on va avoir une augmentation très
importante de la proportion de smicards
en proportion des salariés c'est là le
point qui me semble être assez important
à regarder et puis sur le sur la
mobilisation de l'assuré panne qui reste
pas ce qu'il en restera effectivement
ça doit être mis effectivement au regard
des enjeux d'investissement nous avons
et en particulier d'investissement dans
la transition énergétique nous avons
essayé d'estimer avec ses codes le
montant d'investissement qu'il faudrait
faire pour simplement se mettre sur la
trajectoire du du 01net
enfin du net 0 pardon en 2050 il nous
manque en gros entre 40 et 70 milliards
d'investissements par an donc ça veut
bien dire qu'il y a un enjeu de
mobilisation de toutes les ressources
financières dont on peut disposer pour
les fléchés vers l'investissement donc
la mobilisation de ses terres et de 7
sur épargne à destination de
l'investissement nous semble tout à fait
fondamental pour tenir les objectifs que
l'on s'est assignée dans le cadre de la
réduction nous avions appelé à la
formation de fonds de garantie de fonds
de capital garantie
c'est pour à destination de l'espagne
moyenne c'est toujours une mesure que
l'on porte parce que le elle sera
vraiment fléchés sur l'investissement
lors je n'ai pas le temps de répondre à
tous les aspects j'insisterai
effectivement sur l'aspect italien il ya
quand même une inquiétude assez forte à
voir sur l'italie d'autant que ces
substituts en termes de mobilisation
d'énergie que sont notamment
l'hydroélectrique bien il se trouve
aussi un peu complexifier dans une
période d'absence dos et de forte
sécheresse que connaît l'italie c'est
aussi une circonstance qui va être très
importante qui fait un déséquilibre
énergétique
c'était juste pour ajouter un petit peu
plus
en noir oui où là aussi vous nous avez
pas mais personne ne nous a rassurés sur
quoi que ce soit donc c'est pas tout à
fait l'objet de
cette réunion aujourd'hui mais vous nous
avez dit il assure épargne même si on la
mettait sur les objectifs
en terme donc de transition énergétique
par exemple ou écologique de magna plus
large ça serait une année quoi une année
d'investissements se résout pas tout
quoi bon tout à fait prêts bien
bombée c'est à vous madame un bénassy
quéré alors donc traditionnellement on
laisse conclure si je puis dire
un interlocuteur avec lequel nous sommes
forcément en discussion dans le cadre
des projets qui nous qui nous viennent
et puis vous allez avoir une
responsabilité supplémentaire c'est de
bien vérifier que tous nos collègues ont
eu une réponse est donc si par hasard il
y avait quelques trous ils sont pour
vous et sinon il y aura une petite
bronca à la fin vous verrez c'est très
sympathique
voilà merci beaucoup monsieur le
président je répondrai avec plaisir à la
plupart des questions vous m'arrêterai
quand l'heure sonnera
d'abord pour j'étais d'accord avec
presque tout ce que disait mais mes
collègues je voulais insister peut-être
sur l'aspect
stabilisateur de la conjoncture mondiale
c'est à dire qu'effectivement c'est
l'acronyme tu ralentissent la croissance
ralentie à cause de ce choc d'offre est
basse et stabilisant et en partie que je
voulais donner un petit ordre de
grandeur sur le pétrole parce que le
pétrole russe à peu près 4 le pétrole
russe envoyés en europe dont qui est
soumis à l'embargo c'est à peu près 4 %
de l'offre mondiale c'est un marché
mondial et on voit bien que si la
croissance mondiale ralentie de 1 point
et bien il ya un kart ce choc qui est
absorbée si on pense que 1% de
croissance en moins soit 1% de demande
de pétrole en moins grosso modo c'est ça
et donc ça va assez vite en fait parce
que c'est un marché mondial sperian
chose pour le gaz qui est un marché
local j'étais moins d'accord bon d'abord
sur la conjoncture
tous les indicateurs sont pas
catastrophiques
il ya encore des motifs d'espoir et en
particulier les conditions financières
ont eric a insisté sur les spread mais
le crédit ne ralentit pas il ya encore
très digne d'ailleurs on pourrait s'en
inquiéter mais
il ya encore du soutien il ya encore du
soutien et et les climats tout n'est pas
négatif enfin nous on n'a pas une
lecture complètement sombre delà de la
conjoncture même si ça se dégrade c'est
certain et alors sur la mesure baisse
temporaire des charges là par contre
j'ai un petit
différences d'appréciation je pense que
il ya des théories de l'incident ça nous
dit que tu les hauts salaires ça va
augmenter les salaires des gens qui ont
déjà l'assuré pas déjà et donc ça ne va
en rien à mon avis un résoudre le
problème de l'inflation ni les problèmes
peut-être un peu les problèmes de
recrutement des hauts potentiels ça
c'est vrai mais et le fait que ce soit
temporaire c'est quand même très
difficile 1 et donc c'est pour ça on est
quand même un cirque on se fait par
rapport à d'autres pays qui ont choisi
de baisser la fiscalité des charges et
ses sens et temporaire en france
les mesures temporaires ont tendance à
durer et c'est extrêmement coûteux donc
ces deux manières fin très coûteuse
alors donc j'ai du coup j'en viens au
point central inquiets donc on sait
enchère aux termes de l' échange une
partie de ce qu'on produit va partir
vers le reste du monde même s'il revient
éventuellement sous forme de recyclage
et donc les pétrodollars au petro euro
peuvent financer une partie de notre
transition énergétique ce qui serait
quand même intéressant
mais il y a faim c'est une perte pour le
pays donc ça doit se répartir entre
baisse de pouvoir d'achat pour les
ménages on ne m'a agressé je parle pas
baisse des marges pour les entreprises
et le reste pour le contribuable et le
contribuable c'est de nouveau des
ménages et des entreprises donc enfin on
a beau on dit on reporte sur l'état mais
en fait in fine et les tasses et c'est
encore nous donc je pense qu'il faut
vraiment qu'on prenne conscience de ça
et la lymphe la boucle prix salaires
c'est une sorte de lutte entre les
travailleurs et les entreprises pour
ne pas supporter la perte est en fait le
vrai qu'à chaque tour on récupère on
récupère culte à 100% ça accélère la
boucle prix salaires donc il est urgent
de la ralentir en est bien en faisant
supporter une partie de la charge à ce
qu'ils peuvent donc soit qu'ils ont
accumulé de l'epargne soit qu'ils ont
accumulé des marges pour répartir cette
perte est que ce pas que le contribuable
qui va la supporter et éventuellement de
manière très inéquitable
et donc et là je voudrais faire vraiment
la différence par rapport à aux prix de
l'énergie décarbonée ou si on avait un
choc de prix de l'énergie les gabonais
si les jeans et cannon décarbonée est
aussi cher que l'énergie fossile c'est
pas du tout pareil parce que ça reste
dans le pays et donc on a des
entreprises qui produisent de l'énergie
décarbonée à un prix élevé qui est cette
prix élevés éventuellement on donc on va
répartir c'est une rente ou je ne sais
pas mais ça reste dans le pays c'est
complètement différent comme analyse
d'où l'importance la transition
écologique et d'y mettre vraiment les
moyens alors est ce que l'inflation va
être durable donc la halle donc pour
2022 le gouvernement prévoit en moyenne
annuelle une inflation de 5 % rappelez
vous qu'au début de l'année et s'était
largement inférieurs à ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui
c'est à peu près dans la moyenne des
autres prévisionnistes attention c'est
au sens de l'insee le quand on fait des
comparaisons internationales on prend la
banque de france et donc c'est la façon
harmonisée qui est un peu supérieur
notamment en ce moment où il ya beaucoup
d'inflation énergétique donc tout ça et
alors on peut tous se trompe et c'est
tout à fait possible 2023 il n'y a pas
encore de prévisions officielles mais on
s'attend quand même à un reflux de
l'inflation avec une changement de
composition qui a déjà été mentionné
avec plus d'inflation interne sous
jacente est moins d'inflation
énergétique ne serait ce que par un
effet de base
est par contre il faut distinguer le
niveau qui peut être permanent donc on
aurait une hausse permanente du
coût de l'énergie et puis une inflation
qui elle serait
kiki régresserait de manière graduelle
et donc ça pose en effet la question la
fin du bouclier puisque si on a une
marche d'escalier même si sa'ad cesse
d'augmenter on a une marche d'escalier
il va bien falloir que progressivement
le prix du gaz est productrice it es
rattrap la marche qu'on a ratés d'une
certaine manière volontairement et ça ça
fait effectivement de l'inflation
peut-être plus basse et plus durable
mais en fait et quand on discute avec
les gens de la bcu ils sont d'accord
avec çà çà çà peut in fine est amené à
un niveau de prix plus bas que s'ils
avaient eu une inflation très forte
pendant une période plus courte parce
que ça ça maintient ddd d'anticipation
relativement ancrée et ça ça maintient
une boucle prix salaires enfin disons
contrôler
[Musique]